[inaudible]
joining me today as a trial lawyer focusing on civil,
criminal and constitutional law.
And according to his Twitter bio,
he's America's most successful political gambler.
Robert Barnes,
welcome to the Rubin report,
having to be here.
I am glad to have you here because you sir,
are smack Dab in the middle of a million things that I'm thinking about all the
time.
So I'm glad we're doing this.
Before we do anything related to civil,
criminal,
constitutional,
or any other kind of law,
political gambler,
what or what are we talking about there?
I know what we're talking about,
but tell the people.
Sure.
I started doing when I was real young,
so the,
I used to bet friends and other people with elections and then started doing,
it became sort of legal loosely in 2004 so I started betting on presidential
elections.
I know sort of a side hobby until the Trump election and Trump,
I thought this was a very moneymaking opportunity.
The British betting markets are now much bigger than they ever used to be.
So I could bet as much money as I possibly could.
And,
and,
and basically dug in much deeper than I had before.
So I had sort of been around politics but hadn't done in deep for maybe,
you know,
20 years or so.
I mean I've been very active,
but then it become inactive.
It become skeptical of the political process and decided,
well I should really dig in.
And as part of this,
I discovered this whole emerging movement and a cross section of areas and what
was happening at geologically.
So I became involved for other political and legal reasons along the way.
It was sort of like a Scott Adams when big league kind of thing where you get
the six there somewhere exactly,
exactly.
Where you get like six degrees of separation.
You're trying to learn this.
You ended up learning four or five other things in the process.
And so I,
you know,
I went to the Republican National Convention,
the Democratic National Convention traveled across the country,
talk to tons of people,
dug into what was happening in the social media space,
the reddit space,
the Twitter space.
I didn't know what Twitter was.
And so then really I knew some bird things.
A happier time.
Exactly.
It was,
uh,
and maybe youtube was still youtube,
you know,
it wasn't sensor too.
So the,
I was,
uh,
you know,
involved and invested in it,
went over to the UK,
placed a lot of big bets.
Uh,
they thought I was nuts when I was doing it.
There was like,
you know how Trump's not going to get elected.
That was the sort of consensus.
So much so that one of the big books,
Patty power actually was paying out Hillary Clinton beds before the election.
So if you had been on Hillary Clinton with Patty power,
they acted like you had already won and paid you out.
Are they,
are they still in business?
They are business.
Uh,
though they took a huge hit on the election after they've taken a big hit on
Brexit,
which I'd been on before that.
And then after that had bet on various European elections.
So it was just understanding how the electorate works.
I'm a sports better as well and being able to predict and forecast elections was
fun and it was a way to just make extra money and in the process ended up having
this whole life experience that was fun and entertaining and very profitable.
Can I ask you what kind of profits?
We're talking
about half a million dollars.
Yeah,
it's very nice.
If I could admit that.
If I could a bit more I would've bet more.
Yeah.
There was only limits.
As an American you only have access to the individual betting shops.
You can't get the Betfair and the bet trade in markets.
If I could,
I could have made seven figures,
but they use it would have been
nice cheese.
All right,
well there's a lot to talk about there but,
but I really want to focus on some of the legal stuff because we chatted a
little bit in the green room.
I'm starting to think as much as much.
I obviously am a free speech guy and we're going to talk all about the first
amendment,
all sorts of things that the way the world is going right now with the platforms
and with the trolls and with the anonymous accounts and with the targeted
harassment and with the way that we see media members attacking kids,
which you're very intimately involved with and a whole bunch of others have.
I'm starting to think we really need some legal answers to some of these
problems,
which is really against my default position as a person in terms of speech.
And that's exactly why I wanted to have you here.
So before we get to all that,
um,
just tell me a little bit about your legal history.
When did you even get interested in law and what sort of made you say,
all right,
I'm going to be a lawyer.
Lawyers are that well liked.
Exactly.
Well,
you know,
I've always liked underdog representation and that sort of what my legal
practice is and that goes back to I was a kid.
My favorite TV show is the equalizer.
Equalize the odds and to represent people against,
even if I'm representing someone that's famous or well known,
they're stacked up against someone that has more institutional power or wealth
or the u s government behind it.
And so I was a kid,
I like shows like Matlock and Perry Mason and that was part of it.
And you'd see lawyers as being integral to the process of making meaningful
change and particularly to stand up for people who couldn't stand up for
themselves and use our legal system and legal rights to,
to accomplish and achieve those objectives.
And so that's why the law always appealed to me.
It didn't appeal to me from a moneymaking perspective,
though I've been very,
you know,
had been lucky in that regard.
Uh,
it appealed to me and didn't appear to appeal to me on a status basis.
It appealed to me is I can make a difference for little people.
People like my father who spoke out his whole life and there's a,
and often was punished for it.
And the,
uh,
there's the old biblical proverb that says,
the sins of the father will be visited on the sun.
I always say,
well,
the sins against the father or long remembered by the sun.
And so he was mistreated and maltreated because he stood up,
not for himself,
but for other people in a wide range of environments.
And I just wanted to equalize the playing field if I could.
And was he a lawyer also?
No,
he wasn't.
He was,
he was an accountant,
but it wasn't a certified public accountant.
Uh,
so the,
he went through all the craziness that it was my first experience with the
credentialing society here.
My father was a very skilled and gifted account it,
but because he wasn't a certified public accountant,
he'd grown up in an era where that wasn't necessary.
Uh,
he couldn't get the kind of jobs that other people could do.
And so he was often both overqualified or underqualified for employment.
And then he had a habit of standing up for people who are being maltreated or
mistreated in his work environment or other environment,
which led to him.
And he ended up being a newspaper.
We got delivery guy.
So when I was a little kid,
we used delivering newspapers,
throwing him outside the door.
He,
we did a morning round and afternoon route.
Uh,
and then you end up doing inventory work.
So he just picked up whatever blue collar work he could.
So even though his education and his intellectual capabilities far exceeded what
he could get economically,
it was a product or a side effect of the society and the ability of more
powerful people to take advantage and misuse and abuse that power against the
less powerful people like himself.
Wow.
So,
all right.
So let's flash forward a little bit to what,
what may maybe one or two of the cases that kind of got you,
got you sort of on the map so that now you've become one of the sort of,
I think one of the central legal figures in the free speech battle.
So I started out doing all kinds of free speech representation represented
victims of domestic violence,
was suing big banks before anybody was doing big banks.
And subprime lending was a,
I had clerked for a native American tribe.
I'd clerked for a big corporate law firm.
I'd clerked for a street lawyer.
I always say,
if anybody wants to learn legal education,
just read all of John Grisham's books,
you'll get a good sense of the legal practice really works.
Um,
and worked for a big high profile plaintiff's lawyer and finally got to a space
where I could do the kind of cases I wanted to do.
And I liked first amendment cases and it happened to parallel and two areas of
law.
One was civil where I was representing Ralph Nader.
He went on TV and said,
look,
I'm getting bombarded.
I have no lawyers left to help me.
If somebody can please reach out.
I was like,
sure,
I'll take the case.
So there was,
I remember we did the case in Arizona was me,
Ralph Nader and like 12 lawyers kept coming in.
I kept wondering when the door was going to shut [inaudible] lawyer came in
another,
you had the Democratic Party Republican Party,
both aligned to prevent his access to the ballot,
deny people the right to circulate petitions for the cause or candidate of their
choice.
And so I took that case and it took four years.
A lot of litigation,
a lot of fighting.
But ultimately we've got one of the most important precedents in the country out
of the Ninth Circuit Court of Appeals.
It's now one of the most cited cases in the country that protects the right to
circulate petitions,
the right to speak to the context of elections,
the right to choose who you want on the ballot,
the right of third parties and independent candidates to access the ballot.
In a weird way though,
even though just by the fact that it took four years,
isn't that part of the problem right there?
Cause yes,
four years later it's like he doesn't necessarily have the energy to run again
or the movement kind of moves on to something else,
et cetera.
It was like the beginning of law fair of its own time,
politically motivated,
ideological law,
fair to exclude independent and dissident voices from being able to meaningfully
participate in the political process.
And the main goal and objective is to silence the audience,
to not allow the audience to hear or choose or participate in the way they want
to choose.
They don't get to choose their news,
they don't get to choose their views.
That's what the censorship campaigns were about and that crossed over into
representing people who are accused of being tax protesters and these were
people who had very distinct political views about the way the tax laws were
operating.
They were mostly upfront about it with the IRS.
I mean,
how many people you know,
write letters saying,
I'm not going to pay taxes and here's what some of those,
mostly these were libertarians basically.
Right.
It's never somebody that hates the tax system because they want to be taxed
more.
Right,
exactly.
That's never happened.
Precisely.
Exactly,
and it's people being open and honest about it.
They're not trying to cheat anybody and I tried to defraud anybody in the US
Supreme Court has had 20 years ago in a case called cheek versus the United
States.
They were not supposed to put people in prison for having different beliefs
about the tax laws.
Especially if given this as a country that was founded on people who had very
unique beliefs about the tax laws.
Uh,
so I ended up representing Wesley Snipes in that context.
I'd represented him previously when he'd been falsely accused of,
of uh,
of,
uh,
of parenting a child in New York where they were abusing the family court system
to invade his privacy,
to lie in libel them.
Uh,
and basically t because of his celebrity uses celebrity to make themselves
notorious.
Uh,
so we brought a unique civil rights case in that context.
Had One,
got them to fold and capitulate.
He hired me then to represent them in the criminal case on a whole bunch of tax
charges.
Ended up acquitted of all the felony fraud,
conspiracy charges and even half the misdemeanor charge
on cases like that.
I'm always curious,
um,
when it's a high profiles rich celebrity and it's tax related,
I always think it's like these people move a guy like Wednesdays Nights,
movie star,
you know,
he's worth millions and millions of dollars.
The idea that he would,
and I don't know the specifics,
so please correct me if I'm wrong,
but the idea that he would know every specific thing that his accountant was
doing all the time seems crazy to me.
Like he's running a business where he's mostly probably focused on acting and
traveling and everything else and it's like the idea that unless he instructed
the guy to do something illegal that you'd end up in jail because if something
like that seems pretty bananas to me
completely,
because what had happened with him is he'd had one accountant advisor that he
started to distrust.
He said,
I think this guy's up to something on,
on real estate deals and other deals.
It turned out he was completely right.
He was trying to tell the New York authorities for years before the guy ended up
getting busted and he had,
this guy was involved with Tom Brokaw.
He was representing a whole roster of high profile celebrities.
Turned out he was embezzling from them in mass.
He had abandoned his wife or a stripper long story.
So the this guy ended up going to jail for a long time,
but,
but snipes was like,
hey,
there's a problem here.
And nobody would listen.
And that led them to turn to other professionals and they said,
you know what,
if you have any questions,
we'll go right to the government and get your answers.
And he was like,
well that's gotta be no problem.
They're going to talk to the government.
They'll figure out what it is.
That's how this unfolded.
That's how this whole thing unfolded.
It was in fact,
they even tried to delete and destroy all of his letters and correspondence and
communications.
And luckily they were,
he had separately back them up.
If he hadn't,
we wouldn't have been able to prove how much he had communicated directly to
them.
He even asked to be audited.
He said,
come in and audit me and then come back and tell me what is it io and why it is
I owe it.
And how does the legal system work?
And this is somewhat rooted in the African American and native American
tradition who has a long history of the law is not being applied the way they're
supposed to be on the books.
So the idea that maybe the law is not being applied the way it's supposed to be
wasn't foreign to him.
You have native American tribes whose tribal agreements are still not being
enforced.
You have African Americans between 1865 and 1955 in the United States,
like his parents,
like his grandparents who said the law on the books,
that they had the right to participate in the political process,
the right to be on the jury,
the right to run for office,
and yet that wasn't happening in reality.
So the idea that there was some mismatch here made sense to him and he just
wanted,
he said,
well,
let's go right to the government and I'm Wesley Snipes.
I have a little bit of a tension.
They'll probably answer my questions at least and then everything will get
resolved.
That's why the jury was shocked by the case.
This was a very conservative jury.
The lead jury foreman was a guy who had been a long time corrections officer and
upstate New York.
They had deliberately manipulated the jury pool they'd picked.
It wasn't really an all white jury pool.
So there was a joke that it was as,
as,
uh,
the only thing more white than the snowfall from the Green Bay packer in New
York.
Jack came the day before was the dairy pool in this nice case,
but not in nine of the 12 jurors who are honest and got onto the jury,
said they didn't think he should be convicted or anything.
There were three jurors who were holdouts who said,
we're,
we want to convict them of things.
And we came in with,
they admitted they came in with a bias before they became part of the jury.
So on the misdemeanors,
they did a split verdict.
They said,
well,
will convict them on these three misdemeanors even though we don't think he's
guilty of them,
because that will be no problem.
They didn't know there'd be a wacky sentence because there was shock at the
outcome of the case.
So how much of law is just that?
Just the public attention stuff,
manipulating the media.
I don't have to name,
I could probably name a zillion lawyers that seem like they're far more
interested in fame for themselves.
Then doing the right thing and just managing optics rather than getting to just
what is right.
Precisely.
That's what it often is.
I mean you're seeing it now in the Roger Stone case where there's an obsession
with silence again and all the people on the media on the left that talked about
free speech and talk about the ability to protect yourself and how our criminal
justice system has problems or suddenly muted when here it is.
You have a judge spending all this time saying maybe we shouldn't allow them to
publish a book.
How has that become part of American criminal justice process?
So the effectively,
it often is defending a person in the court of public opinion because often with
the government is doing is using people as sin goats,
using people as sacrificial lambs,
using people to coerce public opinion,
often not really rooted in the facts of the case,
not really rooted in the law of the case targeting people solely because of
their celebrity or their fame.
Uh,
and then you have lawyers who often look at a case and they don't look at the
case about how do I win the case.
They look at how do I get the most press coverage,
how do I get the most media coverage?
And they often deserve their clients in that context.
So it's critically important,
especially in high profile cases to put the client first and to manage the,
the court of public opinion at the same time.
Yeah.
And that cannot be easy,
especially in a day of social media.
I look the fact you're here talking,
so it's not like you're,
you're not like a totally private person.
No.
And yet you want to do what's right by your clients and Yep.
Exactly.
So like in snipes case,
the,
I think the odds going back to high,
the odds are he was convicted of the top felony fraud counts was eight to one.
So there was,
they said there was only about a 10 11% chance of him being acquitted.
You had see,
you know,
people on CNN saying that he had no chance to win.
Some are still prominent legal commentary now.
Uh,
yeah,
you always have legal common commentary,
people on CNN often,
but all the Caitlin networks who get everything wrong and they keep bringing
them back.
It's
like the political commentary.
What,
Oh,
for stress.
And these are people that are mostly never practice law.
Never tried a case,
never dealt with a real gays and,
and it's amazing.
They'll just,
they're there,
they have a law degree,
but they often don't have any legal experience and they're really there for,
or for political purposes.
They know if they say the right thing that they're media bosses want them to say
they'll get,
even if what they're saying is complete and utter nonsense.
Yeah.
So one of the things that I've been saying over the last couple of years,
and you know I'm a free speech guy,
is that right now I'm more concerned that we're silencing ourselves.
Then the government is coming for our speech at this very moment.
Now of course I understand the government can always come for our speech and
there are many ways that you're laying out right there that they can through
going through the IRS or or whatever else.
But I'm more concerned right now about sort of the mob mentality,
the way we're weaponizing the media and social media and the rest of it.
So let's just start with the big question right now.
Social media,
are these publishers or platforms right now,
Twitter,
Facebook,
youtube,
and can you explain the difference between them?
Absolutely.
So all of these big tech platforms originally were able to obtain their monopoly
status two ways.
First,
they got Congress to pass special immunity laws a loosely called section two 30
that particular section of the law is that applies that says,
we're going to presume that everything you do is as a platform and not as a
publisher.
And consequently you'll be immune from any lawsuit as a publisher,
as long as you are acting as a platform.
So meaning that you're just the,
you're just the space so to speak.
People can put all kinds of crap up on there.
You can decide what you take down or leave up,
but you're not endorsing it.
Exactly.
You're just the public venue.
You're,
you're the,
the,
the venue where they're coming to organize the Republican Party on the election
night,
right?
You're the restaurant,
you're the,
you're the convention centers.
That's all you are.
And then that was even additionally privately promised by people like jacket
Twitter who said,
I'll be the free speech wing of the free speech party.
So he induces people to participate and deuces people to become part of Twitter
and to give them an a competitive economic edge against their then competitors
on the grounds that,
and hey look,
one,
the law only applies if we're a platform,
not a publisher.
Secondly,
we are promising you,
we will protect your free speech rights and your free speech liberties.
Now,
it's important in that context.
Free speech means the right to uh,
not be stopped for your speech.
The right not to be harassed for your speech,
the right not to be censored for your speech.
It's both.
That's why I was telling for a free speech is not just the right of expression.
It means I have a rights that someone can target me because of my expression and
use illicit mechanisms.
They can question my ideas,
they can attack my ideas.
If I'm a public figure,
they have limited space in which they can talk about me as a person,
but what they can't do is invade my privacy.
What they can't do is follow me down the street.
What they can't do is put a billboard outside my home.
These are things they can't do.
So is that,
to me,
that's a really fascinating change on the way things have happened because if I
was to look at just generally what's going on on Twitter these days,
if I was to walk down the street right now and somebody just everyday was
waiting outside my house and started screaming at me and all sorts of things,
there is legal recourse.
I could take,
right?
I can file a,
what can I do?
It means that a civil suit and get an order of protection against like people.
Like I did a lot of work back in the day when I was a young lawyer for victims
of domestic violence and we were part of that,
the beginning of the orders of protection that got instituted for them,
but it's not limited to the domestic violence context.
It's anybody who's stalking,
anybody who's harassing anybody who's invading your privacy,
you have an equitable right and illegal,
right to bring legal action against them and have the court say,
I'm going to stop you from doing this and if you violate this,
you're going to be responsible for legal fees.
You're going to be responsible for costs.
I can even put a statutory amount on there and they have to do,
they'll say,
every time you violate this,
it's $1,000 or five thousand ten thousand whatever's necessary to deter.
Those laws exist already there.
So are those laws,
are there any laws related to that that exists in the digital space?
Now?
Again,
I want to be very clean when we're doing this because,
so for example,
all day long trolls are jumping out at me.
Go Fuck Yourself.
You know,
just the word.
It's far worse than that usually.
But like just the worst kind of things all day long.
Same accounts I block on my mute them.
They just make new accounts over and over and over.
Okay.
It's not the worst thing in the world.
I'm still here.
I'm alive.
It's okay.
Um,
but doing it in the digital realm,
I think people would see that very differently than stocking someone just
outside of their house or in the realm of reality.
It is only to a certain degree,
the same laws apply.
So it doesn't matter whether it's the digital world or the physical world.
The same stalking laws apply.
The same harassing loan was apply.
So somebody who stocks can be sued,
somebody who stocks,
they can even be charged with crimes under particular cases so they can be
referred for criminal prosecution.
That's happened to people that have done that too.
Mike Cernovich for example.
So the,
uh,
so you can use civil remedies,
you can request criminal remedies with criminal referrals,
you can bring equitable actions,
you can bring legal actions and of courts are actually very sensitive to it,
particularly like in California where because of the problem of Stalker Razzi
they expanded the do the kind of protection either in the digital space or the
personal space.
And the u s supreme court is increasingly recognized that these days those
spaces are indistinguishable.
So it's interesting to me because as part of the,
let's say,
the free speech crew online right now I'm very hesitant of a lot of this stuff
because it's like I want everyone to be able to express themselves.
And yet I understand we need certain super specific laws,
libel laws,
slander laws,
harassment laws.
And yet there's a certain irony where it's like the free speech crew are the
ones that are going to have to defend those laws is like,
it's like a really weird place for people like us to be in it.
Yeah,
I agree.
The way I think of it as I see it as an unequal equation.
So what's happening is you're seeing big media,
big powerful forces,
people with big platforms be able to defame little people that will be able to
run smear campaigns against people.
It will be able to attack and,
and encourage stalking and harassment and online mobs at will and not be held
responsible.
And it's the little guy that's still fighting for their free speech.
And yet they're the ones,
the little guy who's getting sued by big institutional actors are backed by big
institutional players and they're being sued for defamation.
They're being sued for liable,
they're being sued for there being the platform.
And so we need to do is equalize that playing field because the first amendment
is also about protecting everybody speech.
And that means the little guy can't get harassed in ways the big guys immune
from and the big guy can't use powers that the little guy doesn't have access
to.
So it needs to be equalized out.
So true.
Free speech means people who are important in the independent press and the
freedom of press of the independent press,
not be harassed,
not be,
not the legal system,
not be used against them,
disproportionately indiscriminately not have the d platforming happening against
them disproportionately indiscriminately.
And that's what's taking place.
And that's what needs to equalize.
So true free speech means we need to have some equality of treatment between
everybody.
Okay,
so now backing that to the platform,
verse publisher a part of this.
So they,
they help get these law.
What statute did you say to section two third section two 30 okay.
So they,
they help get these laws passed.
Now they're treated as platforms,
but it seems that they're acting often more as
publishers,
right?
They now admit that.
So in other suits that I brought against Twitter,
they said that they are a publisher and they want all of the protections.
As a publisher,
they went all the legal privileges of a publisher because the publisher has a
wide range of special protections,
particularly events has any institutional former backing.
So there are certain libel laws that apply to individuals differently than they
apply to corporations.
The same is true of big media publishers,
so they're now saying to courts,
so in the Prager suit against youtube,
youtube in Google's defense is we're acting as a sensor,
we're acting as an editor,
we're acting as a publisher and look at all these privileges we have as as as a
publisher,
which a lot of people,
and it was one of the issues we raised was if they're acting as a publisher,
they shouldn't have the immunities of a platform.
Unfortunately the courts have interpreted what congress said to them in a
political way,
and this is often the case with a lot of law,
a lot of laws that interpreted through a political framework and how they
interpreted it as,
oh,
the Co is congress doesn't want us to allow big tech to be sued.
So we're going to give them all the protections as a publisher and all the
section two 30 immunities as a platform.
So they have a degree of protection.
As senator Holly described it,
a degree of immunity and benefits that no publisher in the world has,
that Congress is the one that actually gave it to them as the courts have
construed it though somewhat argue.
That's beyond what Congress intended.
Right,
so Prager lost the initial lawsuit.
Correct.
Are they,
and I know Dennis,
but I actually don't know the answer.
Are they pursuing other illegal measures?
You're still trying to go through the appellate process,
but they're unlikely to prevail under the current environment because the
current environment is such that like the,
when I pursued Twitter,
I brought unique novel theories.
I brought breach of contract theories,
a consumer protection act theories,
because my equitable theories,
because my view was Twitter had lied to people to induce their participation,
profited from that participation sold.
That person's like someone like Charles Johnson would come in and 30,000 other
people joined Twitter to follow Charles Johnson.
They now have all of their private information.
They get to aggregate that information and then marketize it and monetize it and
then they get to censor in band Charles Johnson forever from Twitter because
they don't like one tweety mate.
Well,
if my view is that's really a breach of contract,
that's really a breach of equitable duties and obligations,
but the court saw,
oh,
Congress is saying section two 30 means I'm not supposed to allow Twitter to
ever be sued for anything.
That's what's happened and that's why Congress needs to fix that side of the
equation because unfortunately the courts haven't stepped up to do it
themselves.
Do you think there is an interesting piece of this that is just because of
anonymous accounts and I don't know what the legal protections or non
protections would be around that,
but if you generally look at what's happening online,
if you,
if we removed anonymous accounts and by the way,
as a free speech guy,
I'm not for that because I now understand the off many times,
many times.
I mean I see this with people that I meet at live events.
They'll come up to me after and they say,
you know,
I have an anonymous account because I'm a conservative and I don't,
so it's not that they're trolls,
it's not that their flame flaming people or whatever else it is.
But there's a piece of me that thinks,
man,
if you just removed anonymous accounts and put,
put aside the decent human part of it for a second,
sure.
That actually 80 to 90% of all of this nonsense would disappear because you've
got brave keyboard warriors with no skin in the game that are trying to so
havoc.
I don't know if there's a legal piece of this somewhere.
There is a legal way to do it.
So if you're an operating on an anonymous account and you're doing something
that's not protected by the first amendment,
like stocking,
like harassing,
like,
uh,
like invading someone's privacy,
which is a broad tort that covers a wide range of remedies,
including like in the Covington pay case,
we'll bring the first case that establishes that doxing is in fact an invasion
of privacy.
So,
uh,
you can sue,
you can require that Twitter or Google,
whoever did it,
Facebook identify that individual,
uh,
and,
and consequently that individual can be held legally liable for their course of
conduct.
So people who think they can hide,
they can do bad things behind anonymity or wrong,
they can do good things behind it and enmity.
And the First Amendment and compas is that in an entity is often critical to all
kinds of free speech.
But if what you're doing is always been outside the scope of the first amendment
like stalking,
like harassing,
like intending to censor and chain people based on lies and libels,
you can be held individually liable and you're an anonymity of your account will
not protect you from legal responsibility.
It's so interesting because I'm hearing you on all this and then there is this
other,
this,
there's the absolute as part of me on speech that even though I know we need
these protections more than ever,
there's just this little piece of me that's like,
ah,
I don't want everything to get caught up in legal ease.
And that,
and I guess that ultimately is the balance that guys like you have to deal with
every day.
Yeah,
absolutely.
It was the pitch that we made to senator Holly was don't treat these as
utilities and start to regulate them.
I understand why people are calling for that because what they're seeing is
monopoly power.
The interesting thing is in the first amendment,
including in California,
uh,
and to,
it used to be the law and it still is the law in some places,
which is if you have the effect of a corporate monopoly on the public square,
you are then considered a state actor for first amendment purposes.
This was established way back because you had company towns who are like,
well,
how do we suppress this union movement?
Well,
why don't we just own the whole town?
We only share if we own the copy on the public square.
Now band petitioning now we'll ban circulating.
Now will they had organized.
So by that definition,
you would argue the social media companies are absolutely okay.
It's called the [inaudible] doctrine here in the state of California,
which applies to private malls.
Private moles can't ban you from circulating certain things in the public spaces
of those private malls.
Well,
is there any more monopolized public square than big tech media than Twitter,
than Facebook then youtube than Google.
They own,
they own 85 to 95% of the public square and all corporations are creations of
the state and they get certain protections for that because they have a
corporate charter.
They're given certain immunities from individual liability for participating in
that company.
Well,
in exchange for that,
once they get to the place where they monopolize the public square,
those two things exist,
both of monopoly and the public square,
which is usually over 75 80% control of a market space.
When they have that,
and when it's the public square,
I think they should be held to the same first amendment standards as everyone
else because otherwise we create this huge loophole in the first amendment to
privatized control of the public square.
So,
uh,
Eric Weinstein,
who I'm guessing you're familiar with,
I had a couple of discussions with him about this and one of the ideas that he's
put forward,
and my libertarian side doesn't really like this,
but,
but I see some value in it is that because we don't,
we don't have public spaces online,
so it makes everything,
so in effect,
everything's private.
There's nothing public.
So the government has nothing to do with anything.
But maybe this would be an actual good use of the government if there were
platforms that were government platforms that the only rule basically was,
you can't break the laws of the United States so that people could get their
information out there,
but you,
but if you break the laws of the United States,
you're in trouble.
Then the private companies could do whatever the hell they wanted and we'd have
no reason to.
We'd have no ability to stop them.
But in effect,
because everything is private,
there's nothing public anymore.
Right,
exactly.
And so my view is that once you become a monopoly,
and particularly when you become a monopoly based on federal congressional
immunity,
then you have different obligations than any other private actor.
So that's one argument.
One argument is if you become,
if you become a month,
if you choose to have a monopoly in the,
in the public square space,
you're going to have the same first amendment rules as any government actor.
That's one option.
Another option is just to condition their continued immunity on First Amendment
inclusion.
Those are the arguments that I made to the Twitter lawyers.
In the Johnson case.
It was like,
look,
you guys don't have to reinvent the wheel.
Like well they said they were worried about stalking and harassing and I was
like very simple.
Just take all the first amendment rules that already exist,
incorporate them within your terms of service and then you'll,
you'll eliminate 90% of your concerns and questions and you won't have to deal
with a lot of the nonsense,
right?
Like right now,
there rules would be considered void for vagueness if they were staying in
because you have rules that are subject to individual women discretion and
they're intentionally written that way.
Right.
So let me,
did you catch a any of uh,
Tim Pool and uh,
uh,
Joe Rogan with Jack?
Exactly.
Yeah.
And he detailed this instance after instance after instance.
I mean the way they decided to Ddi Platform,
Alex Jones was highly subjective,
very interpretive.
And I've seen far worse,
I mean,
for example,
the Covington case,
you had a prominent Hollywood figure show,
an image of saying the saying the Covington kids should have to go through a
shredder and be killed.
You had raise as long calling from the be punched in the face.
Nothing was done about that.
And yet,
uh,
Alex Jones posts something that's just a funny video and they're like,
oh my goodness,
we have to get rid of Alex Jones.
Okay.
So I want to spend a whole bunch of time on cutting team.
Cause I think actually that was the moment that this shifted and maybe at a
legal sense it crystallized in my mind a little bit more.
That's actually when I reached out to you,
cause I saw you just going for going for it.
And I thought,
okay,
this is a conversation you have to have,
but let's,
let's talk about Jones for a minute.
So Jones,
so you've,
you've done some defense work with Jones and then presenting Alex Jones and info
wars and now his outside general counsel on all these legal matters.
So you represent him across the board on all of these things.
So I guess my first question is what's it like when Alex Jones,
you know,
knocks on your door or calls you up?
Know he's a very animated guy,
very nice guy,
very open,
very sincere.
When was fascinating from the get go,
he was saying 90% of what they're saying about me,
it doesn't isn't the case.
He's like,
I would defend us on for on free speech and free press grounds anyway.
But what they're actually saying,
I said,
I didn't say I never attack these families.
I never went after these family.
Never told people to go to the families' homes.
None of that.
Yeah.
So this is,
that stuff specifically is about the sandy,
exactly.
Sandy Hook case.
And so that they're either,
they took a media matters video and assume that's what I said and it wasn't
really,
they took most of that out of context and didn't put in that I had corrected the
record long time ago.
Um,
and so part of it was very nice guy,
actually very friendly guy,
very accessible guy.
Even more so than snipes.
He gets mobbed when he goes out in public with people hunting selfies and that
sort of thing.
Um,
and he doesn't act like the Jaguar did with a lady very nice and sociable and
friendly.
Um,
so the uh,
runs it,
you know,
nice small business enterprise access TV to talk radio to Internet and he's
intended to be the poster boy of their d platforming campaigns.
They,
they,
when I told the press is this case really isn't about Alex Jones.
It's about the ability of the independent press to operate.
Uh,
we'll law fair be discriminately or desparately used against ordinary
individuals in the same way that d platforming is happening already in the big
tech space.
And so are we going to protect the little guy or not?
And Alex Jones,
they figured would be the convenience.
They would sort of create a parody of them,
a caricature of them that they could get the public to believe,
make them,
make the audience feel bad if they watch him.
The uh,
may feel guilty to be associated or attached with them.
And as soon as my representation was announced and another lawyer,
norm Pattis big old school civil rights lawyer in Connecticut,
I think he still has a pony tail.
I mean,
he's old school.
He had friends and family members that are connected to what happened at Sandy
Hook.
So he,
uh,
immediately,
you know,
wanted to be involved in the case.
As soon as he was Huffington post writes a hit piece on,
they don't talk about a civil rights legacy.
They don't talk about any of that.
Its entirety.
The whole thing is intended to smear them.
And it's sending a message that if you're a lawyer and you dare to fend Alex
Jones,
we're going to try to destroy your reputation in the public space.
And that's exactly the problem that needs to be fixed and remedied.
Yeah.
So related to Jones specifically,
I mean one of the things that I thought was was most incredible,
I forget the exact order of it,
but basically within 48 hours,
all the platforms,
so came down.
Yes.
And it's like,
okay,
is that,
is that that you guys truly your calling each other and coordinating it or is it
that you're all sort of cowards,
you somebody breaks the ice and now you're just followers and I don't know that
it matters either way.
Right?
It probably doesn't matter either way,
but what I thought was okay,
it doesn't even matter what he has said.
Short of breaking in American law,
in my opinion,
the real issue here is that if he can't be on there,
then why is fire can on there?
I'm not even,
I'm not making a comp comparison.
Direct comparison to them.
Why is Hamas on there?
We could do a zillion other things.
You know,
it is fair.
It is obvious and evident.
There are people who have said far worse things that just happened to have a
different ideological or intellectual perspective.
Even if you took all the accusations against them at face value in 90% of them
are not true.
The what and that's your typical smear campaign.
The conservative or the person on the right or the person on the independent
anti war left will often be attacked and smeared.
90% of what's said about them is not true,
but even if it was true,
what the other side has said is usually far worse and far more great.
Jackson,
far more accessible and it's the obvious disparate treatment they're using
their,
they're concentrated power to,
uh,
any including their law fair power to effectively wipe out the little guy so
that only the big guys voice is heard and all.
To me it's about the audience because that Jones is still gonna talk.
It's just candy audience here.
So it's about their right to choose their right to choose what news they want to
look at,
what views they want to have,
what,
how they filter information.
I always say like,
like I don't represent people that are accused of racism or the rest people that
are actual racist.
Not everybody these days,
everybody's right were being accused and being an actual races are greater,
but the people who are really involved in something,
I generally avoid representation of them.
Um,
the uh,
because I just don't want to be affiliated it just because that is an old
personal issue.
But if you look at what those people,
I've always said,
let those people debate.
Because if you watch Richard Spencer debate somebody else,
99% of the time,
the Nice,
calm,
reasonable person is not going to say Richard Spencer is right.
So always expose ideas to more ideas,
more sunshine because let the ideas get,
let trust the audience.
That's really what they're all saying.
The all we're big tech is doing what these big lawsuits are doing against little
guys is intended to say we don't trust the audience to make up their own mind.
We don't trust the audience to make up their own decisions.
We have to control what you think.
We have to control what you do because you might choose something that we don't
want you to do if you actually have freedom of choice,
freedom of thought,
freedom of expression.